la registrazione avviata questo momento
per esordire davanti 5 milioni di
persone da ciccio ciao ragazzi ho
rancesco merino iscrivete il mio calare
vivrei questa fase tento di prendere in
contropiede tutti tu sei l'unico che in
quel che sà sfruttarla al meglio vi
iscrivete grazie merita la vita
quest'uomo e anzi facciamo il cambio che
io faccio vi do sul tuo il tuo pedoni ok
aspetta questa è tipo pantene se quando
la vita ti sorride tuoi capelli fanno
istruisci ma riesce a fare cosa fai tu
guarda come capelli o fai switch off
ma in che senso vero non lo so
allora va bene allora ragazzi che spiega
un secondo come si fa cosa faremo oggi
grazie a ciccio caputo vestite
incredibile io avevo in mente di fare
una non ridere challenge non la facciamo
da una vita
però lui ha aggiunto un po di pepe alla
situazione metteremo dell'acqua madonna
che tamarro metteremo dell'acqua nelle
nostre cavità orale in comunemente del
tè bambo che è visto come sono colti
5.000 iscritti così che ho fatto non
sono anch'io come sono seri diamo la
tastiera tanto è di marco quindi per lei
si alzano bene tutto è pronto ma che
abbiamo iniziato che succedette a dio
mai sfuggito a svetta stavo pensando se
se parte sto video e continua così
pasticceria casinò sono stati un po
verso diversi
ma con due no mi piace piacere
sapevo che in caso spiega negati e vi ho
provato a salvarmi prima e sparisci che
sia qui la sua conclusione di luca salvo
della motogp
[Musica]
gli errori contro se si rompe non già
capito allora facciamo di distanza
quello che attira trovata è stata che
male si è fatto quel che madonna che è
male tutti però è un gruppo militare
te lo giuro bello america maria mi devo
calmare mai un tempo gaia tutti che
tutti vuoi te lo giuro non hai capito
non hai capito quanto sono andato vicino
al vomito da ridere cioè perché quando
trattengo l'acqua ora mi avrebbe
tantissimo non ho idea non era tanto
perché faceva ridere però non date non
fronte quello più l'acqua e
troppo e poi finisce male lo sto dicendo
e finissimo tutto male mamma mia quanta
dura ancora scrive devo ancora a metà no
ti prego dio non c'è un minuto da qui
[Musica]
si no
no
[Musica]
o è difficilissimo ma se che non avevo
mai fatto così con l'acqua con alcol e
matita ci disse questo è possibile
my fire da piccolo mio fratello a creare
delle storielle è più box scusarci
faccio anche questo non è che per ora
comunque intenzione di una mamma mia che
ha preso la farfalla non c'è roncello
caccia marca farla vivere solo di ma
direi a questo punto di farne un pelo
più soft poi per concludere però senza
l'acqua no no no no senza la passalacqua
stata in corsa tempo è brutto
io te lo volevo dire questo qui a
mentire
no che non perdeva solare ciao è stata
improvvisata una sera bellissimo ei
capolino rimessaggio preparandoli a 9
volte
sarà impossibile che presteranno ad hoc
ed enti è stortissima c'era ma lui era
convinto di fare scoprire questo motivo
non mi sbaglio dai non vuoi fare dire
così mamma mamma e basta
questo quando ho scoperto che pc30 volta
al giorno picchiate sistema comunque io
questa cosa vorrei puntualizzare to pc30
volte al giorno spiega per allora ho
problemi o problema che io ora notte mi
alzo un sacco di mora perché il pc 30 m
relativi fuori questo io bevo un sacco
perché weber sia vero anche se avrebbero
visto il problema è che sono anche al
dottor il dottore mi ha detto il fatto è
che idea dei funziona così tanto bene
che piscina ma 30 volte al giorno ma
neanche non risorgere bruno pesce
percepisce non lo so che c pc nomi penso
è una biscia pesce una biscia bis
continuiamo come gatti non mi piacciono
a me piace il kinder bueno purché
buttana pure a me lo voglio fare un
altra roba che detta scusa neanche a un
cane devi censurarli no no va bene graal
ha fatto lui va bene tu non censure
resti dei partenti me con delle partenti
me sì di altre cose per g20 parigino di
raffa ragazzi serviamo una meno di un
elefante o in calo di un gatto di un
cavallo ed un commento letto perché
hanno censurato le palle del cane quando
cielo quella perché chi infatti denuncia
il cane va a firma obama ha firmato
bravissima comunque ragazzi spero che
non c'era una sega perché come ho
bagnato tutto che vorremmo asciugare e
da un po che non facevo una crono ridere
challenge non ho mai fatto
e lui che ha avuto l'idea dell'acqua se
non ci comitato un altro poco
chiaramente se non si tratta di stare
male o pomì da non puoi barbie testo si
tratta di quello però vabbè però vi sia
piaciuta era da veramente una vita che
non facevo stata però è lanci strano
tanto tardi che mai ma gli ho mai fatto
meglio ma i ragazzi sono visti aiuta
cose mi piace ancora cercando vestizione
dove si discute e non ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo vi va bene che hanno questo
aspetto
no scherzavo ci vediamo al prossimo vita
da ragazzo ma 800 euro di tutta
[Musica]
ma